the ultimate mark of respect
falling silent as they watched the
ceremony inside
from their screens outside after the
minute silence
a celebration for his royal highnesses
life
the duke of edinburgh was their
neighbour windsor is a town they shared
with him
and it feels today like they've lost one
of their own
overwhelming to be in this situation to
be standing outside
today of this funeral um but i feel like
it's
the right thing to have done for people
to be able to come up today
and just be all together really i think
it was just important just to just to
make the effort to come
and and be part of it like i said
although you can't see anything
it's just to know that it's going on
behind the wall there
they have been told not to come with no
public processions and everything kept
behind castle walls
but many like the lynch family felt
compelled on her majesty's 90th birthday
the duke picked out elizabeth's then
four-year-old son from the crowd
so he could meet the queen personally a
memory they cherish
especially today it's a sad day it's
just
you know not just for us um but for the
country and
especially obviously for the queen and
her family
we've experienced loss ourselves um you
know
my father passed away last year and so
it's still quite recent
so we understand that it's you know
the losses is hard it'll be it'll be
difficult for them i think
the few on the long walk who came to lay
flowers reflected on the scaled back
proceedings
wishing the public had more of a part to
play
bigger bigger it is a big event it
should be the largest single event
of this generation because of its
contribution
we should give him a state funeral
service
not because he wants it but because the
work that he
did for the nation deserves it
for towns steeped in the pageantry and
history of the royal family
those commemorating the duke's passing
on the streets said goodbye
to one of their own ashna haranag sky
news